I see you looking across there my hunch
is we're going to cross that sucker it's
got to find somewhere to do it yes
that's the thing that's scary it looks
terrifying
you know I'm pretty terrified of heights
but as I've gotten older I really wanted
to experience all these things and I was
really dying to get out here in nature
push myself to a place of being
uncomfortable I mean I'm talking to you
and I'm you know
I'm on the edge of a cliff so I asked
for it
wow
oh
yes here is our spot
get the out of here
okay so yeah that is our direction of
travel we can either keep contouring
along this
try and drop down there and cross
somewhere but this is I mean it's a long
way down but it's probably the narrowest
point so you say instead of repelling
down go across
okay and then go to the Batman
okay so this is a grappling hook gun
that's pretty nuts basically it fires
line out we try and get it to catch
amazing and then we tension it up and
then once we're sure it's solid we're
just you know old school right Pioneer I
still am confused by it so you'll show
me yeah okay so this goes on then we get
the grappling hook this goes straight
down
red is fire green is safe oh and then to
charge it we push the trigger forward
this goes to 100 PSI so first you've got
to make sure it's fully charged and I
reckon with no wind the range is only
about 125 feet so I'm hoping it's going
to reach once we fire it got to be
mindful we don't want it going over the
edge right so keep a hold on to that
okay
Ray me for a bush we got some windage
we've got strong winds so we're gonna
need to aim off a little bit as well
now that the grappling launcher is
assembled we need to take some other
factors into consideration
the Ravine is a hundred feet across
already on the edge of the gun's range
but on top of that we've got a 30 mile
an hour wind gusting in from the south
that means unless you angle off the shot
is gonna miss wildly
you you know all of this stuff from
American Sniper I mean you had did you
have to do a lot of sniper training I
did do a lot of sniper training that was
a long time ago but we did factor in the
wind and actually the orbit of the earth
and all that stuff yeah yeah yeah and it
gets super technical isn't it it's just
incredible so you've got to remember
this okay for tomorrow you're gonna need
your room no no the thing that I haven't
really banked on is the idea that I have
to retain any of this information
there were a couple of things red uh
blue 100 thing uh big kickback
but we'll see how it goes
okay we ready
one two three
wow
good catch
yeah that would have been because that
is sweet that has gone right in that
book that was amazing fingers I've used
these a lot over the years they are
incredible bits of Kit and once they
grab onto something and they go under
tension they're not gonna let go but
ultimately you can never get complacent
because if that rope goes slack then it
can pop out
that's it that's good super strong in
these lines will weight it first it's
down here and as long as it holds it's
good great
now that the grappling hook line is
secure I've reinforced the ropes added a
pulley and we're good to go okay check
check
foreign
and don't look down
okay so gravity will get you to here and
then you've got to pull yourself across
it looks a little hard
a little it's a little windy this is the
moment where I really put my trust in
him because uh
a bungee jumped once in New Zealand and
I thought I was gonna kill myself I was
so terrified I thought and this is kind
of what this feels like so um it's going
to be one of those moments where you
just have to take a leap of faith so I'm
gonna go with that thought process as
I'm uh Crossing
the abyss as it were okay you ready yeah
and Bradley once you drop off
keep your hands away from this yep when
I drop
don't touch anything
here we go
[Music]
thank you